so it goes on class 10 from italy and
now i'm totally human
i'm coming a little bit
vary here
i have no idea but good
look there what that leads to also plays
something five i still think it's a
bit funny
i don't understand anymore  different the idea
of ok I really didn't threa
en well not reall
clear that this is impor
ant here but yes I actua
ly thought the four that should be go
d center like
or
s
it too limp well well I have
o you have
o  sometimes prevent
the 4
so and now the highest railway
to open the
statement so I had to deal with my 46 once because otherwise he just makes ash w 40
now I wanted to take the sprinter to
ca well can still maybe fulfilled
so he plays okay  okay now a5 or
something like that he has of course patrick nuo got
dirty now so see that it might
stay closed for the moment
now open here we
could do well objectively I
think I have real
problems here of course it's still all
very complicated but c 303
somehow worries me more time
I hope now it's on cd because it's not
jaha 3 if I had tried everything
somehow quickly
I can take c4 with the lady
the 5
if I did it now but
you wouldn't surprise me like that
yes ok
I don't really see how I
am here now
although there is of course some
prospect of
yes ok right to
take the sources of course  not so
now because a 3
doesn't have that many attacking
pieces anymore so it was going somewhere now
that's the time the problem attack
he doesn't have it clear now
then david b1 shaft but after
king c3 which I think
that was definitely somehow makes na
yes, definitely very funny